khed mhal the former leader of Hamas has
declared today a global day of jihad
specifically throughout the West after
the terror attack last week on the state
of Israel this is unfortunate as later
today I'm scheduled to travel to my old
stomping grounds of New York City which
happens to be by the Numbers both the
most Muslim and the most Jewish city in
the United States it is also of course
the site of the worst terror attack in
American history also perpetrated by
radical Muslims
lots of people throughout the West are
changing their plans today closing
offices closing schools staying home and
I'm all for Prudence but I am very much
against worldly fear which is why I'm
not changing any of my plans today a
good explanation of why not was once
given by a sort of personal hero of mine
Richard Overton who died 5 years ago at
the age of 112 Mr Overton was at that
time and for some years prior the oldest
surviving World War III veteran he
credited his longevity in part to
smoking 12 cigars a day and putting
whiskey in his morning coffee you can
see why he was a personal hero here is
some advice that Mr Overton had on war
and life at the age of
109 you see a soldier with a gun you
don't see him turn around go back to
shorty he may go sideway but he ain't
going to turn around and go back uh-uh
don't care how hot them bullies is he
ain't going to go back so you when you
go in there you say well God got me
now
see he going to take care of you if you
want if it's your time to go that bully
going to get you if it ain't your time
to go that bully going over your head it
ain't going to hit
you go man will kill you but God's the
one to keep you
ly
there are two kinds of fear relevant to
the global day of jihad worldly fear and
fear of the Lord fear of the Lord is the
beginning of wisdom it's a gift of the
Holy Spirit a reverent fear akin to awe
that perfects Our Hope of remaining in
God's grace worldly fear is the opposite
it's selfish cowardly and opposed to
Freedom fear ye not them that kill the
body and are not able to kill the soul
but rather fear him that can destroy
both soul and Body in hell are not Two
Sparrows sold for a farthing and not one
of them shall fall on the ground without
your father but the very hairs of your
head are all numbered fear not therefore
better are you than many sparrows I'm
Michael nolles this is the Michael nlls
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the show Breaking
shocking news Jada Smith and Will Smith
have apparently been separated for six
or seven years now shocking breaking it
actually is somewhat shocking because
they said they wouldn't get divorced we
we will get into that because it
actually has political
ramifications first though the war is
spreading the Israel a force uh struck
Damascus International Airport yesterday
in Syria they did this a day ahead of
the Iran foreign ministers visit to
Syria so they didn't take out the
Iranian foreign minister but they
certainly sent a warning message and now
the war is not only in the state of
Israel it's not only in Gaza it's not
only in southern Lebanon it's now also
expanded to Syria what is the US
interest here the US interest is to
contain the war
other nations have other interests some
Nations might have the interest of
regime change in Iran some Nations might
have the interest of expanding the war
Beyond where it is already some Nations
might have all sorts of interests this
is the holy land we're talking about
this is a very prized piece of real
estate and every even semi- major power
on Earth has some interest here the US
interest is contain the war obviously to
retrieve our hostages as well I consider
that almost a separate question but as a
matter of War policy you're going to
hear a lot of voices clamoring for more
war regime change bombing the
malas somehow attacking trying to weaken
Russia through this war and not merely
through the war in Ukraine uh China is
kind of sitting on the sidelines here
they didn't quite come out and condemn
the Hamas attack or they sort of tried
to do it but there are going to be a lot
of people calling for more and more war
including us senor Senators that is not
the American interest the American
interest here it's not to stay at home
and put our heads in the sand the
American interest is to contain the war
as much as possible uh speaking of
foreign policy voices some people are
now asking how we got into the position
where we could have a global day of
jihad and have Americans have the Brits
have the French have all people
throughout the West afraid of such a
day the obvious answer is to how we got
there was mass migration and no less a
foreign policy architect than Henry
Kissinger Henry Kissinger Secretary of
State for Richard Nixon the man is 100
years old the man has been an
influential foreign policy architect for
well over half a century what now for
something like 60 70 years Henry
Kissinger said the key the big mistake
here Mass
migration what a great mistake to let in
so many people of totally
different
cultural and religious and
Concepts because it creates a pressure
group inside each country that that's
said very Politically Incorrect you're
not allowed to say that Henry Kissinger
look Henry I know some people hate Henry
Kissinger Henry Kissinger has has made
some mistakes in his career I think the
clearest example of a mistake Henry
Kissinger made was that he was one of
the biggest proponents of soccer in the
United States He is credited uh with
driving the increased popularity of
soccer so I'm not saying the guy always
got things right but he does have a lot
of wise things to say and he's totally
right about this this is something that
all serious Statesmen and political
philosophers have known for all of human
history and yet today even conservative
Republicans are not allowed to say it
when conservative Republicans attack
migration they they or criticize it in
any way
they have to say well look I support
more and more legal immigration I think
we should have endless legal immigration
but I'm opposed to Illegal
immigration yes illegal immigration is
worse than legal immigration but Mass
migration is the problem over the last
60 70 years we have seen the largest
movement of people ever in recorded
history of people moving into the United
States uh that's a problem when you mix
groups of people that don't have very
much in common it creates conflict this
is this is an observation that Dante
hear is in the Divine Comedy from his
illustrious ancestor in Paradise in the
Canticle that is taking place in heaven
uh Dante's illustrious ancestor kagua
says yeah the problems really began in
Florence when they started mixing people
around who didn't have a whole lot in
common you you got a lot of conflict he
is clearly right here this is something
that the West needs to deal with the
West right now has no limiting principle
on migration the West has convinced
itself that its culture is is totally
open to everybody that there there are
no requirements for becoming a part of
this culture that there's no legitimate
reason to keep people out of your
civilization that there's no legitimate
distinction between Citizen and
Foreigner that there's no legitimate
distinction between nations and other
nations the West has convinced
themselves of that obviously the left
but a lot of people on the right as well
self-styled conservatives and so here
here you have Kissinger coming in and
saying at even if he made some unwise
decisions in his in his youth the guy's
100 years old I think he's probably
learned a thing or two he says Mass
migration was a grave mistake
unfortunately we're learning that a
little bit late at this point but it's a
lesson that at the very least we should
learn right now we got to talk about it
when you want to talk to your friends
you got to check out P talk right now go
to Pur
talk.com I've got to tell you about
something that speaks to the very core
of what we believe is Americans about a
veteran-owned company on a mission to
make a real difference in the lives of
our military members I'm talking to you
about pure talk here at the daily wire
we love what Pure Talk is doing our
veterans gave everything they could to
protect our nation and P talk
understands the sacrifices they've made
they've set an ambitious goal to
eliminate $10 million in military debt
by Veterans Day but they can't do it
alone they need your help when you
switch to purer talks Lightning Fast 5G
Network they will donate a portion of
every new order to this noble cause you
can make a real difference just by
choosing Superior cell service P Talk's
plan start at just 20 bucks a month
offering unlimited talk text more data
and mobile hotspot just go to Pur
talk.com nscw Lees to make the switch
you will save a lot of money you will
get exactly the same great service let's
rally together and show our unwavering
support of veterans PT talk.com noes to
switch to P talk today it's the right
move it's the American
way speaking of our
democracy a whirlwind of news has
occurred in the House of Representatives
and we haven't even really got got into
it because foreign events have been a
little a little bit more interesting and
a little bit more pressing but you know
that a handful of Republicans and a
bunch of Democrats threw out the former
Republican Speaker of the House Kevin
McCarthy then there was a race for
speaker and there were two guys who
threw their hats in the ring that was
Steve scalise who has been on the
leadership track for a long time among
Republicans and Jim Jordan who is
terrific he's a favorite of many
conservatives uh according to measures
of candidates conservatism and
anti-establishment ISM uh Steve scalas
was certainly more the liberal
Republican candidate certainly more The
Establishment candidate and Jim Jordan
was is ranked much more conservative and
much more anti-establishment and
unfortunately when the Republicans met
behind closed doors because this is this
is not a popular election this is an
election for members of Congress uh
Steve skes Won and it was somewhat close
it was 113 to 99 but still scal clearly
won and this was viewed as a uh an
insult to Donald Trump because Trump
backed Jim
Jordan so this was played out in the
media as once again Donald Trump loses
once again the Republican party not
heating what Donald Trump has to say uh
however to me that shows that nothing
has changed really since 2016 it has
always been the case since 2015 2016 up
through the present that most
professional Republicans Republican
politicians political commentators GOP
Consultants most of them have opposed
Trump and the kind of candidates that
Trump
endorses what's been strange about that
is that most Republican voters support
Trump so there is a Divergence between
the professional Republican class the
professional conservative class and the
actual conservative voters who decide
the elections at The Ballot Box when
elections are decided at The Ballot Box
uh that's what happened in 2016 all of
the disproportionately the the
Republican journalists talkers
commentators pundits strategists blah
blah blah electeds they were against
Trump didn't matter Trump kept
dominating in the primary then in 2020 a
lot of people who had opposed Trump sort
of softened because they had no other
choice and they they would have been
totally shut out of Republican politics
like Bill Crystal or uh David French or
those kind of people uh had they
remained opposed to Trump so they kind
of softened on Trump a little bit but
then 2024 rolls around and many of the
same people if not all the same people
come out and oppose Trump again this is
no surprise at all now you might say
well I I think it was a dumb idea to
nominate Trump in 2016 or it's a dumb
idea to nominate him in 2024 I'm not
making any comment on the wisdom of
doing that or not I'm just pointing out
that there is today as there was in 2016
as there basically always has been a
major disagreement between the
professional
conservatives and the ordinary
conservative voters that is happening
again and it's playing out yet again in
the primary forget about the house race
for a second it's playing out again in
the primary because
disproportionately the GOP Consultants
the donors the talking class the the
pundits the they favor other candidates
than Donald Trump Ronda santis Nikki
haly maybe Tim Scott and
disproportionately the voters at least
according to every single poll favor
Donald Trump over those other candidates
that's just a disagreement among the GOP
and the people are going to say that the
pundits are idiots and the pundits are
going to say that the people are idiots
but that is simply a fact and when it
comes to electoral politics and
democracy it's probably wiser probably
wiser to be on the side of the people
now getting back to the house race Steve
scales even though he got the Republican
nomination he just dropped out of the
race because he didn't have the
votes there were conservatives in the
GOP caucus in the house that said we're
not going to vote for Steve scalise and
we've got such a razor thin majority in
the Congress and and scales is not going
to get the votes of the Democrats so
sorry scalise you're out which means
that that Jim Jordan still could be the
speaker which I'm really upset about not
because I don't think Jim Jord would be
a great speaker I think he'd probably be
the best speaker we've had in a long
time but because I really like Jim
Jordan and I think he's a good guy and I
wouldn't wish that job upon him because
that job is the worst job in Washington
DC being the Republican speaker of the
house is I would rather be cleaning out
the Porta John on the National Mall
probably than being the Republican
speaker of the house it's totally
thankless it's very difficult to succeed
it's like hurting cats but on the bright
side we could get a pretty good speaker
because it could be Jim Jordan now
speaking of uh what's going on in
Washington DC this is one of my other
reasons to keep Jim Jordan out of the
speakership is it not he would be great
he would be so phenomenal he's a
terrific guy but he does great work on
the Judiciary Committee and he's done a
great job investigating Democrats and
look at the stuff that we're getting
right now Joe Biden has just been
discovered to uh have exchanged
29,000 emails with family and business
associates of the Biden family
from his vice president email
account so Joe you know Joe Biden had a
number of pseudonymous email accounts he
came up with all these pseudonyms to
conduct the particularly Shady business
while he was VP but among the this is
according to America First legal which
does a great job on unveiling this kind
of stuff he used his VP email account to
exchange more than 29,000 emails with
his son Hunter with his brother Jim
Biden with their business groups
which directly
contradicts claims that Biden made
during the 2020 campaign and what's
really strange about it is it means that
Joe Biden must have a lot of thoughts
about the weather it's a because Joe
Biden initially he said I don't know
anything about my son's business I don't
even I don't know what he's doing then
he said okay maybe I know a little bit
maybe I heard had a few conversations
but I wasn't involved okay maybe I was a
little bit involved maybe I wrote some
handwritten notes to his business
partners maybe I invited them to to
lunches with the leader of China maybe
uh but I you know look I it's not like I
was in these meetings I was say okay I
was in these meetings I was on more than
20 phone calls with Hunters business
associates but this is what the excuse
became I only I was only talking about
the weather we were just exchanging
pleasantries 29,000 emails about the
that's more emails about the weather
than Al Roker has ever sent that is no
one has that many thoughts about the
weather I'm starting to think Joe
Biden might have been conducting some
shady business now speaking of troubled
families we've heard for years that Will
Smith and Jada Smith have a little bit
of a difficult marriage this came to a
climax when during the Oscars Chris Rock
made an anod joke about Jada Smith and
Will Smith got up there and smacked him
across the face it was very very strange
but for years they've Will and Jada
Smith have been open about uh cheating
on each other and you know Jada Smith
had some very young boyfriend and it
just seems rough but they said we're not
going to get divorced
ever bad bad marriage for life which was
a play on Bad Boys for life and well now
Jada Smith has revealed to the Today's
Show that she and will have been
separated for seven
years why did the relationship
fracture oh why it fractured that that's
a lot of things and I think by the time
we got to 2016 we were just exhausted
with trying I think we were both kind of
still stuck in our fantasy of what we
thought the other person should be Jada
says she considered a legal divorce but
could never go through with it I made a
promise that there will never be a
reason for us to get a divorce we will
work through whatever and I just haven't
been able to break that
promise good that's good I know
everyone's going to attack J Smith
because she seems just absolutely Ely
awful in most ways but I tell you that
is a really redeeming statement that she
just made she said even though we have
this terrible relationship and even
though it's Hollywood so everyone gets
divorced and even though we've been
living separate lives and even though
we've been cheating on each other and
even though we've been doing this and
that and the other
thing I can't bring myself to get a
divorce because I made a vow and it just
seems wrong and even me living in
Hollywood being a big lib doing all this
crazy stuff even me I know it's wrong
and I don't want to do it good good
follow that voice Arnold Schwarzenegger
has a self-help book coming out he just
came out and uh explained that he
doesn't want to talk about the explosion
of his marriage anymore because that is
the biggest failure he's ever had he
said I blew up my
family no failure has ever felt worse
than that Darius Rucker from hoodie and
the Blowfish he he just split with his
wife after 20 years of marriage he said
you feel like a failure you try to
express those feelings and it's hard to
say and it's hard to put that on paper
you try to do it as real as you can I'm
not a big talk to you guy but I can sit
down and write a song about it that
stuff hurts you feel like a failure but
we're still a family a piece of paper is
not going to change that we're still a
family and that's all because Beth is
awesome she knows it's best for the kids
she's a great human
being
okay you see really big people here
really big successful lauded praised
people saying divorce is the biggest
failure I've ever ever had I in some
cases saying divorce is such an a scary
failure I I can't bring myself to do it
even though we're separated some people
saying I did get divorced and I'm rich
and I'm famous and I'm powerful and I'm
this and I'm that I was the governor of
California and it's the biggest failure
ever even huge stars are claiming that
the biggest failure they could possibly
have is
divorce J Smith saying even with our
awful marriage I can't bring myself to
do it and and then hoodie and the
Blowfish over here Darius Rucker makes
an even more insightful point he says
we're still a family he says even though
we've been
divorced we're still a family it's we
got this piece of paper that says we're
divorced but we we're still involved
with each other's lives we still we
can't pull away from one another which
is an observation that some of us have
been making for years divorce is
practically speaking almost always
impossible especially when there's kids
so you know the church says the
Christian view is that divorce is not
possible what God has joined let no man
say
separate uh certain Christian
denominations accept divorce but the
vast majority do not and for the vast
majority of of the history of the church
divorce has not been recognized or
accepted in any way and obviously the
Catholic Church still holds to that
um even if you don't believe in God or
Christianity or religion or anything
like
that the point expressed perfectly by
the church that divorce is not a
possibility what God has joined no man
can separate is expressed by Darius
Rucker in this really practical way
where he says you know just practically
speaking we still got the kids we still
see each other we still talk we still
have to interact with one another so you
can't you actually just can't do it it's
not possible and I I hate to give
Hollywood some credit here but they
deserve a little bit of credit which is
there the the people who seem most
likely to divorce these Hollywood
stars they're warning people about the
reality of that they're saying don't
fall into the same thing that I've
fallen into it's not pleasant it's not
even really possible now when you want
to feel nice and good and healthy uh you
probably also want your dog to feel nice
and good and healthy that's why you got
to check out Ruff greens right now go to
Ru greens.com
Michael you know my pal Matt Walsh has
been giving rough greens to his dog I
don't have a dog I'm not a huge dog
person but I decided to send some to my
stepbrother who has this beloved little
miniature Australian shepherd type thing
that I don't really like but I want to
make sure the dog gets good food so I
sent it to him naturopathic doctor
Dennis black the founder of Ruff greens
is focused on improving the health of
every dog in America I had no idea that
dog food is dead food it contains very
little nutritional value think about it
nutrition is not brown it's green let
rough greens bring your dogs food back
to life rough greens is a supplement
that contains all the necessary vitamins
minerals probiotics Omega oils digestive
enzymes and antioxidants that your dog
needs you don't don't have to go out and
buy new dog food you just sprinkle rough
Greens on their food every day dog
owners are raving about it it supports
healthy joints improves bad breath
boosts energy levels and so much more
head on over there right now get a free
jump start trial bag so your dog can try
it a free jumpster trial bag can be at
your door in just a few business days
Ruff greens.com melm AEL or call 844 Ru
ruff1 123 that is rfffg greens.com
Michel or call 844 rough ruff1 123 today
the two most important decisions that
you will need to make this month are as
follow as follows one trick or treat you
got to pick one
two yes or no yes or no is the perfect
Halloween party game especially with the
new conspiracy theory expansion pack
tackle topics such as aliens Cryptids
vampires demons for all your Halloween
hot takes if you already have the
classic game be sure to secure the
conspiracy pack in time for all your
spooky sarees don't wait go to
dailywire.com shop today my favorite
comment is from Devin Rossi
5966 who says if climate control is the
greatest threat we face then the
thermostat in our homes is a greater
weapon than we could have ever guessed
you make such a good point the greatest
threat that we face is the sun monster
ticking up the temperature like at one
100th of a degree every thousand years
and so what that means is you need to
arm
yourself not with a gun not with a
nuclear weapon no with that little
thermostat in the one just
go okay problem solved we're good we're
good now very do you do you work for uh
Skunk Works or something are you working
for some very clandestine
weapons
development Realm of the US government
cuz that that was a brilliant
observation speaking of Hollywood
Gwyneth paltro just revealed where she
stores her Oscar and I love
it and what a beautiful Academy Award my
door stop it works
perfectly I love it it's a sort of a te
he haha look we're filming this little
take on Gwyneth P's home and oh my
goodness outside she's she's got her
Oscar as a door stop oh yeah it's a
great door stop I love this this is a
really healthy attitude when it comes to
something like Fame there was a uh
famous uh journalist magazine editor and
Catholic priest who uh in his home he
kept all of his pictures with Statesmen
and prominent people in the bathroom and
friend of mine once asked this man why
why are they all in the bathroom he said
because that's exactly where the glories
of this world belong is in the bathroom
uh this is a healthy
attitude when it comes to something like
Fame especially Hollywood which is so
rotten where nothing really is as it
seems where so much of of Hollywood is a
facade and just beneath the glitz and
the glamour you have Decay and you have
you know uh the decline you have the
collapse of families and you have people
selling their bodies to get parts and
you it's just pretend I mean the whole
place is just pretend and so when when
you're faced with something that is
pretend what ephemeral really fleeting
then that's a good way to treat those
glories uh that would not be a healthy
attitude however when it comes to
something that really matters like
family like honor like dignity like
piety like
sanctity then you would not want to
treat that as just something to be left
out in the rain to stop up your gate
outside or anything then you would want
it you would want to cherish that you
would want to treat it very well and one
of the big problems in the modern world
is we totally flip it so in the in the
modern world we treasure Fame and
notoriety and clicks on social media we
treasure that as our most dearly held
possession we would never leave that out
in the rain stopping up a door no we we
spend our efforts we spend our time we
spend our our love on that and we let
things like you know family honor
dignity modesty uh we we we forget about
that
stuff you don't need to be a Hollywood
store to recognize this how many people
sacrific their family on the altar of
career or on the altar of professional
ambition or on the altar of fun on the
altar of Hedonism on the altar of
selfishness we do that all the time this
is real some people are going to look at
winth palro say she's totally crazy
she's being disrespectful to the academy
and to Hollywood by this top
professional achievement she just thr no
that's where it belongs is out in the
garden it belongs out there stopping up
a
door we need to cherish the things that
are worth cherishing we need to uh keep
in proper perspective the things that
might seem glittery and pretty in this
world but will not last speaking of
Health only 2% of Americans have
received the
new
[Music]
uh before we
go uh Andrew Tate is in the news yet
again Andrew Tate you know is something
of a favorite among a certain segment of
young right wiers uh he's also an only
fans pimp who who's a criminal in
Romania because because of his pimping
because pimping ain't easy and it also
ain't legal in a lot of places uh and
Andrew Tate is also a a convert to
Islam so I I guess that's better than
being an atheist but I don't know his
version of Islam doesn't seem even like
the best version of Islam and uh Andre
Tate's reaction to the Hamas terror
attack on the state of Israel uh and now
the ensuing war is there is but one
certainty in this mess there is no God
but Allah and Muhammad
pbuh what is oh peace peace be upon him
is the messenger of Allah that was his
take right after the terror attack that
was his take on October
7th and he's in some quarters probably
not as much anymore but in some quarters
a conservative
icon this reminds me of a good rule of
thumb you are known by the friends you
keep you are actually known by the
friends you keep and the kind of circles
that Andrew Tate is moving in actually I
do have a a couple PE friends of mine
who were friends with Andrew Tate but
broadly that would be the exception to
the rule I think and because they were
friends for a long time uh but of of the
people that Andrew Tate is cavorting
with now you know The Pimps and the
prostitutes and the radical Muslims and
the that doesn't generally speaking you
know you you look at that and you say
that's not he's probably not in
agreement with me on a lot of things and
then you look broadly at the pramas
argument and the pramas argument is
being joined by BLM BLM is totally crazy
it's being joined by the radical leftist
it's being joined by Harvard students
but I repeat myself it's and you look
around and you say
huh I don't want to be totally
prejudicial here but generally you are
known by the friends you keep are you
still getting your chocolate from woke
companies get Jeremy's chocolate instead
right now you can save big with 25% off
get great deals on our famous Heim with
nuts and she her nutless uh in full size
or our sharable microaggression size
perfect for giving out to friends and
family time is running out so stock up
now in time for Halloween go to Jeremy
chocolate.com
today finally finally we've arrived at
my favorite time of the week when I get
to hear from you in the mailbag mailbag
sponsored by P talk P talk.com today
take it away Hey Dirty Mike Mr reality
here I had a question for you on the
potential of World War III breaking out
a lot of people say that because uh we
have nuclear weapons Russia has nuclear
weapons China has nuclear weapons all
these major Powers have nuclear weapons
that there would never be another world
war my thoughts are no one's going to
actually use their nuclear weapon unless
they're about to be utterly destroyed
because for example say United States
invades part of China um is China really
going to launch nuclear weapons and
destroy all of China at our retaliation
immediately or are they going to fight
at the border and only use the weapons
if there's no other choice so my
thoughts are the nuclear weapons are a
defense against total annihilation of a
country but not against the world war
itself uh what are your thoughts on that
thanks yes uh the the nukes we're seeing
this happen right now the nukes are not
deterring Regional or multi-regional or
at what point do we call it global
conflict um but I'm I'm not agreeing
with your point that the nuclear weapons
would not be used except in some kind of
existential situation we have hav't seen
it yet we haven't seen tactical nukes
exactly but people have this idea that
nuclear weapons you know the moment you
set one off basically the whole world
explodes and that's not really true it's
not that's not really how nuclear
weapons work nuclear weapons are are
very scary and it's not a good thing to
use but we've set off a lot of nuclear
weapons especially when we were testing
the nuclear weapons forget about use in
war obviously at Hiroshima and Nagasaki
um but we've set off a lot of nuclear
weapons it didn't didn't end the world
the uh fallout and the blast zones and
everything are are sign significantly
smaller than than a lot of people think
for most nuclear weapons so I'm not
quite so Placid that they won't be used
in in some war in some tactical way
maybe not one of these you know nuclear
weapons that blows out a city uh but
some kind of nuclear weapon I'm not I'm
not convinced that that could not be
used just because they haven't been used
in 70 years 70 years is a pretty short
time next
question hello Michael L cre AIX Maximus
if you don't mind I would like to ask
your opinions about one of the
contentious topics of the Catholic
Church's history that being the fabled
female pope Pope Joan do you believe her
story to be that one of Truth fiction or
a little of K A and A little of C be
love to hear your response this Friday
and wish the best for you and your
family especially given your recent
comments about
Biden thank you very much good question
for those who don't know Pope Joan is
this
legendary uh Fable you know as as you
say uh female pope from I think the 9th
century uh and then this was uh you you
see I is it in Sienna Cathedral or in
one of the one of the cathedrals there's
actually a bust of Pope Joan you know
this this legendary female pope uh
though that was removed pretty quickly
after it was put up and in 1600 or 16001
the then Pope said it's a it's fake news
it is fake news I'm I'm I don't see any
evidence that Pope Joan existed or that
Pope Joan was actually a woman probably
the Fable comes from a pical attack on
one of the Pope John's from the uh eth
or nth Century maybe 10th Century I
guess um but no it's a kind of a fun
story I like these fun stories I like
Legends the thing about Legends is while
Legends are not true they often have
some semblance of truth even legends
about the saints that that probably did
not literally happen tell you something
about the character of the Saints and so
as a pical attack on one of the actual
male popes uh it seems to make much more
sense than a woman just secretly
becoming Pope next question hi Michael
I'm going through what's called The
Quiet martyrdom of The Virtuous Woman
and I'd like to have your advice on it
um basically what this is is that when a
a virtuous good Christian woman is
younger
um guys don't want to be with her
because she's virtuous she won't do
things on dates um you know she waits
for marriage and now that we're older in
our
30s good virtuous men don't want us
because we're in our 30s even though
we've already been through the trial in
our 20s um so you do have advice for us
U these women looking
for her vocation as a wife and a mother
in her 30s and seems like nobody wants
us thanks
Michael great question you are
truly one of the chief victims of the
sexual
Revolution
the probably your group in particular is
the is the chief Victim Because the
sexual Revolution says forget about all
the old rules forget about honor and
Chastity and modesty and sexual ethics
sleep around if it feels good do it and
some women don't want to do that but men
come to expect it then men maybe they
sew their Wild Oats and then they decide
to settle down and get married but uh
they don't want to then they find some
you know hot young thing or something
22y old I'm not saying you're not a hot
young thing too but you know you as you
point out you're you're though perhaps
hot uh somewhat older than the 22- year
old girls and so you you find yourself
in this pickle where you know you've
you've done the right thing in your 20s
and now you say well now nobody wants me
I I think that that latter part though
is just not true I have I have many
friends in authorities who were in the
same spot as you and even even uh
friends who were not you know totally
chased in their 20s but they're still in
the same spot as you I mean they're it's
because the problem is just so much
broader the delaying of marriage for
everyone is screwing things up for for
women in particular uh my advice though
is there are a lot of men who are in the
same position I get this question from
men probably just as often as I get it
from women we're saying hey I'm in my
30s and I just haven't met a girl who
likes me and I don't know how to go on
dates and I don't how to do anything um
so my my advice to you would be go go
where the men are you know go my advice
would be go to a traditional Latin Mass
because everyone's pretty young and is
on the same page as what you're talking
about and they're interested in getting
married and having like a thousand kids
so I don't know if you're Catholic or
not I don't I don't I don't know what
your circumstances are in that way but
you've got to go where the men are and I
would be a little forward because you're
saying oh these men don't want me and
I'm unlovable and I'm undesirable but
you're giving the men too much credit
you're thinking that these men are all
Larios and Don giovanis but they're
they're usually not the men are are just
as awkward and and incapable of
interacting with the opposite sex as as
you I think maybe mistakenly think
yourself to be that the sexual
Revolution just blew up sexual relations
it's it's you know not just just one sex
or the other so I would recommend going
where the men are in real life in real
person joining clubs going to the right
kind of a church you know this that and
the other thing and I'd approach the men
and say hey you want to go get a cup of
coffee I know it's weird I know it's
weird but sometimes you know in when the
culture has gotten so completely crazy
and chaotic you've got to be a little
unconventional to get back to normal
next
question hi Michael my name is mallerie
I'm a 20-year-old college senior and I'm
also a cradle Catholic last week you had
a few segments on your shows talking
about SS ssris and other mental health
drugs um I just wanted some advice I
have been on ssris for about a year and
um I've struggled with major depressive
disorder my whole life since I was
probably about six or seven and I can't
imagine going back to my life before I
started these drugs because they have
helped me but I wanted to know your
advice from a faith standpoint on things
I could do to improve my mental health
through God thank you so much I love
your show thank you so much really
really great question and I'm I'm not
saying that these drugs can never be
helpful at least for a short period of
time I'm not saying they can be helpful
but I'm not I'm not saying they can
never be helpful uh I am quite convinced
that one in8 Americans should not be on
these drugs and when you take men out of
the picture when you just look at women
it the numbers are even crazier I am
convinced of that I don't think that we
should be pumping powerful psych drugs
into a huge proportion of our population
including very young people um but maybe
on the rare occasion maybe it does
something to help you along the way you
you raise this question at the end you
say do you have any any uh advice
regarding faith that could help my
mental health question so I I guess I
would need to know where you're starting
from
because obviously you have not perfectly
identified the source of your pressive
problems you're saying that these drugs
work so that's I'm glad you're feeling
better than you did before and you've
had this from a very young age I would
just wonder if maybe some cognitive
behavioral therapy might be helpful here
if maybe some spiritual counseling with
a a priest might be helpful here because
is it the case that you know your
parents got divorced at age six and and
you and then you got depressed at age
seven and never got over it many such
cases
uh well in that case I would work
through that issue is it that a loved
one died when you were six or seven and
that that spurred your depressive
episode which has persisted for a long
time is it that you your family had a
crisis of Faith at six or seven and that
has led over time to depressive episodes
I just don't know so I try to identify
that problem and to to to give you a
really blunt answer on faith it is in
fact the case that one ultimately cannot
be happy without a healthy attitude and
direction toward God it is it is not
possible uh we've known this since the
good old ancient Greeks up through
modernity and as the modernity has
turned away from God people have gotten
miserable so uh I
would to quote Andrew claven I would
live as though God exists for 60 days
just pray and go to church and be act as
though God exists and uh see what that
does to you and then I would try to
identify if if it is possible I'm not
saying it is maybe it's just a quirk of
your brain but uh if it is possible try
to identify what might be underlying
your depressive condition because more
often than not I think there is a uh a
reason that one can point to that is not
just totally uh random uh last last
mailbag question you get to before we
get to the mail block we have a really
important mailbag or a really important
mem block segment today but mailbag
question mother-in-law drama uh Michael
I had a question regarding a situation
with my mother-in-law this woman is not
the kindest person is very two-faced one
day she'll smile at you the other she's
sending my kids hand written letters
about how much of a piece of work I am
while also sending angry text messages
to me regardless of all this my wife
still likes to have her visit and this
year I decided I would leave during the
time she's visiting when my wife picked
me up from the airport she started to
cry and go on about how she needs me
home when she visits because it's too
much without me there she states that as
her husband I should support her while
her mother is there my question to you
is part of me says I should be there but
after close to 20 years of this I'm at
my boiling point and if I see her I will
say all the things I've held back what
would be the best way to go about this I
feel like I'm stuck between a rock and a
hard place yeah you you let this go on
too long um so there's no way to fix the
past but for instance if your
mother-in-law uh sends letters to your
kids dissing you that is when you calmly
call your mother-in-law and say hey
you're out you're out we're not going to
see you for a little while and you're
going to need to fix your behavior and
you're going to apologize to the
children for doing this and scandalizing
them and if you don't do that we're
never seeing you again and because I'm
the head of my household and this is my
family and you're not going to threaten
it even you to whom I owe some modum of
respect that's why I'm calling you
respectfully uh but you can't do this
this is my family I'm the head of my
household uh you know that would have
been a good thing to do 20 years ago I
guess now it's a little bit late for
that probably I don't know how old your
kids are you maybe you had kids later on
in your marriage um so it's in the
little things that the rot begins to
quote the Butler on the crown so it uh
you know these things fester and fester
and you say now I'm at my boiling point
I think you're right though you
shouldn't flee when your mother-in-law
comes to town okay you it's your house
you're you're the head of the family so
you actually do have a responsibility to
be there you know you you have a
responsibility to your wife and to your
family to to do that and to and to keep
yourself in composure and to be patient
but to be firm too you know I just
wouldn't I just wouldn't accept these
kinds of things I mean I know it's very
hard I I love my mother-in-law I have a
lovely mother-in-law I know people who
have had very bad mother-in-laws I know
mother-in-laws who have destroyed
marriages luckily you're not at that
point yet but I generally agree with
your wife and I think that you've got to
be fmer but do not lose your uh cool a a
man does
not fall out of control you know part of
being a man is being being in control
but I would I would be firm and and
clear and
uh recognize that you're you know you're
in charge of your family not your your
mother-in-law is not the head of your
family the rest of the show continues
now we have a reporter who's on the
ground in the Holy Land uh a
correspondent for I24 for news who has
been giving wall-to-wall coverage she's
been as in it and on the front lines as
anyone can be of this major war breaking
out that could be the beginning of World
War II so the rest of the show continues
now do not miss it become a member use
code nescs at check out for two months
for on all annual
[Music]
plans